[Music]
in Europe in the sixteenth century most
people drank beer instead of water the
brewing process killed all of those
nasty microbes that were found in your
average 16th century cup of water so
beer was actually the cheapest safe
beverage available when coffee and tea
became widely and cheaply available in
Europe thanks to the opening of trade
routes with Latin America and East Asia
in the 17th century they offered a new
safe alternative to water and the
subsequent transition from drinking
mostly alcohol to drinking mostly
caffeine coincided with the most
technologically productive period in the
continents history the Industrial
Revolution I love this correlation
because it illustrates everything that I
love about history history pushes us to
be curious about cause and effect as a
kid I assumed that these brilliant
scientists and inventors that I had
learned about who invented the steam
engine who learned how to harness coal
and produce electricity were solely
responsible for our being ushered into
the modern era but studying history real
history messy history shows a very
different story where the Industrial
Revolution was dependent not only on
these brilliant inventors and scientists
but also on Europe's transition from
being permanently drunk to permanently
caffeinated history shows us how small
changes in the way that we live our
lives can trigger massive societal
transformation historians study the past
to uncover the unintended consequences
of our actions we're not always
encouraged to think like historians here
at the GSB in fact I think most of us
would probably consider ourselves
students of the future after all this
place is dedicated to the things that
haven't happened yet and the people who
are about to dream them up but I think
that we all should think
like historians see I think that Silicon
Valley needs to learn how to think like
historians here we only consider the
past for long enough to figure out how
to disrupt it we're not often
preoccupied with unintended consequences
and so many of the innovations that
we've built are actually causing bigger
problems than the ones that they set out
to solve in the first place
to better understand the impact of our
innovation we need a better framework
for mapping out cause and effect we need
to understand the impacts of our actions
for example the National Safety Council
realized that car accidents increased by
12 point three percent over a five year
period due to an increase in distracted
driving which is really really just a
euphemism for not being able to put your
smart phone down or traffic congestion
in San Francisco it's gotten worse right
it's increased by sixty percent over the
last ten years and more than half of
that is attributed to Oberer and lyft
and Airbnb is accused of decreasing
long-term housing stock in cities that
are already facing housing shortages and
affordability issues so how can we learn
to think like historians here in Silicon
Valley to minimize risk and to mitigate
some of this damage well thinking like a
historian means looking closely at what
we're leaving behind first of all
historian spends a lot of time digging
through primary source records and
artifacts which can be broadly
classified into two different categories
trash and triumph trash is everything
that the people in the past meant to
throw away triumph is everything that
they intentionally left behind for us to
find and both are equally important in
understanding what life was actually
like in the past and historians have
learned just as much from ossified food
remains as they have from the
hieroglyphs that are carved in the walls
of the ancient pyramids when it comes to
understanding what it was like to live
in ancient Egypt now I would argue that
we
spend too much time focused on the
triumph and not enough time looking at
the trash when it comes to understanding
our impact here now sure the triumph has
an interesting story to tell about our
priorities as a civilization and a
society just as the ancient Egyptians
built pyramids to house their dead
leader gods Jeff Bezos
is building a 42 million-dollar clock in
the desert as a testament to technology
that will continue to function for
millennia sure interesting story but the
trash has a really important story to
tell to the trash tells a story about
how our lives are changing in the most
mundane but often most fundamental ways
historians have learned so much about
who was trading with whom
by studying discarded pottery shards and
tracking them through ancient trash
dumps and we too can learn about the
behaviors and patterns that our
innovations are encouraging by studying
the things that people did not intend to
leave behind what does the refuse in a
rideshare drivers trunk say about the
amount of time that he has to spend in
his car what do the deleted direct
messages in a teenage girl's Instagram
account say about the experience of
being a young woman online in addition
to looking at what we're leaving behind
we also have to understand whom we're
leaving out we need to ask questions
about whose voices are missing from the
stories that we hear of our impacts
historians know all too well that there
is no such thing as a reliable narrator
everybody's explanation of the facts is
tinged by their own unique perspective a
horrifying bloodbath and a justified
seizure of power are both valid
descriptions of the French Revolution
depending on where you're standing in
1789 the historians job is to piece
together these multiple perspectives to
get a comprehensive view of what
happened and why when it comes to
building technology and developing new
ideas
it's easy to lose sight of that big
picture view and get trapped in our own
perspectives just look at the myriad
tools that we've built to solve problems
that are only relevant to the urban tech
elite think an uber for dog walking app
that's currently valued at 300 million
dollars
seems a little unnecessary we need to
ask questions about whose voices are
missing from our understanding of the
worlds we need to be more curious as
businesspeople and technologists what
would happen if we stepped out of the
view of our direct customers and
interviewed people who are impacted by
the second degree effects of emerging
technology what might we learn there's a
sort of historical hubris here in
Silicon Valley there's a sense that the
things that we're building are going to
change the world and we know exactly how
and why whenever I hear a tech CEO or a
start-up founder of venture capitalists
talk about how their company is going to
change the world I can't help but think
about my favorite little nugget of
history see the introduction of caffeine
to the European populace may have helped
to spur the Industrial Revolution but
there's no way that any conquistador or
merchant could have possibly known that
as they carted bushels of tea leaves and
coffee beans across oceans and deserts
the introduction of new goods to the
European market could have very easily
pushed history in a different direction
highly relevant to today the bubonic
plague which killed every third year a
peon in the middle of the 14th century
was also a side-effect of open trade
small changes can trigger destruction
just as easily as they trigger
transformation and innovation we need to
better understand our impact and to the
questions that historians ask to study
the past can help us do this Isaac
Asimov once said that great science
fiction writers don't imagine the car
they imagine the traffic I sure wish
that uber had imagined the traffic when
they built their app we all need to get
better at imagining and fixing the
traffic that our innovations builds and
the study of history can help us ask the
right questions so that we're building a
future that we all actually want to live
in thank you
[Applause]
[Music]